- I brought you here for
more than just a view.
- Oh yeah?
- I have to say,
the last five years have been
a nightmare come true for me.
- Yeah.
- Will you be my ex-wife?
- Oh, my God!
Yes, of course I will divorce you!
- Yes?
- Oh, my God, baby, I hate you so much.
- Oh, my God, I hate you too.
We're getting divorced!
- The more I think about my future,
the more I don't want you in it.
Will you give me my ring back?
- Yes!
- Your kids are gonna love
having two Christmases.
- Mom, Dad,
we're ready to end this (bleep)!
- Oh, I knew he wasn't the one!
(screaming in delight)
- Oh, my God, now you can travel
whenever you want.
- You're gonna be so happy sleeping
with other people, honey.
Well, Daddy's little girl can finally
spend all night alone
watching reality TV again.
- Aw, Dad.
- My friend, Denise, had a divorce.
She recently had oral
sex with Jason Derulo.
- We've had some good times,
some bad times.
Let's just call it even.
- Okay.
I still get half your money though, right?
- Yeah.
- You must be so tired
of riding the same dick
for the last five years.
- Ugh.